ha regresado la tensión desde que la
prensa estadounidense anunciara el viaje
a taiwán de nancy pelosi presidenta de
la cámara de representantes- que si se
confirma se convertirá en la visita de
mayor rango en 25 años ya ha advertido
pekín de que tomara medidas contundentes
y no es extraño porque a china le
solivianta cualquier contacto oficial
entre washington y taipei recordemos la
tormenta que generó años atrás la
llamada de la presidenta de saint wayne
at run para felicitarle tras ganar las
elecciones dijo trump que no entendía
por qué eeuu puede venderle armas a
taiwán pero su presidente no puede
atender una breve llamada de cortesía y
tenía razón porque todo lo relacionado
con taiwán está lleno de sinsentidos por
ejemplo que eeuu venda armas a un país
que no reconoce para defenderse de un
país al que si reconoce o que castiga a
los gobiernos que dejan de reconocer a
taiwán para reconocer a china es decir
por hacer lo mismo que hace él pero esa
estructura con todos sus sin sentidos y
cinismos y con su apariencia frágil ha
evitado los conflictos en un asunto muy
delicado durante décadas
lo que ahora parece estar en peligro por
los esfuerzos de washington de
incrementar los contactos oficiales con
taipei y de cruzar líneas rojas hay
voces en washington que incluso piden
reconocer a taiwán lo que para pekín
sería un casus belli incluso baiden dijo
recientemente que la apoyaría
militarmente en caso de guerra con china
aunque después lo desmintió es seguro
que la cuestión de aguán esa será
tratada por sí baiden cuando hablen por
teléfono la próxima semana si la
enfermedad del segundo lo permite si le
ha deseado hoy una pronta recuperación
del cobi